《红楼梦》经历十二拆里,史乡云的细分删除最为严重。这直接导致原住里跟乡云相关的各种设置出现了自乡矛盾。按照原住的描述,史乡云出身经领史家从小父母双王,又年时期被家母接到荣国府居住,跟贾宝玉亲没主马一起长大。甚至家母还把习人送去服侍乡云,从某种程度来,
史乡云简直是另一个林代域。故而,张爱林在《红楼梦》演义书中,就通过丝丝入扣的《红楼文本》分析,认为《红楼梦》的稿子曾进行过大幅度的删改。
早期《红楼梦》稿的时间线,既有可能比我们今天看到的要长得多。甚至史乡云,长居家府的文字也都是有的,后来全部都被删去了。
其目的自然是担心和待遇尽家府乡重。因此,许多细心的读者会发现,《红楼梦》里有些文字是对不上号的。
比如第37回《海堂诗设》,众人其雅号,李湾说家宝玉曾有个旧号叫《降动花主》,只验摘还专门在旁边披了一句,妙及又点前文。
通不中从头置默,前文已过者恐惧之冷落,使人望怀,得便一点,未来者恐来之突然,或先服一线,接行文之妙觉也。
显然只验摘当年神稿的时候,草血情写得非常细。
包括家宝玉,降动花主雅号的产生经过,故而到了《海堂诗设》这里,重新议题就起到了又点前文的妙用,直验摘为此大赞行文之妙觉。
可我们今天看到的《红楼梦》里根本没有所谓的前文。
降动花主的称号突然冒出来,又突然消失,在家宝玉里玩的交谈中草草带过,之后就再也没有出现了,跟披语连接不上。
这样的例子有很多,布红金在之前的文章里也多有论数,而我们今天要重点谈论的是史乡语。
按照最初红楼梦的时间线,史乡语的年碎一定比今天的版本要大的多,至少比林代玉要大。
红楼第三十二回,史乡语作客一红月,跟习仁聊起小之后的事情,这段对话很值得细细研究。
习仁针了茶来与史乡云吃,一面笑斗,大姑娘听见前儿你大喜了,史乡云红了脸吃茶不达,习仁斗,这回子又害骚了。
你还记得十年前,咱们在西边暖哥住着,晚上你同我说的话,那回子不害骚,这回子怎么又害骚了。
这段对话显然是根据早狗的年龄现写的。
此时史乡云刚刚订婚,习仁说他大喜了,乡云的表现是红了脸,从侧面正式了这一点。
可基本中,史乡云的年龄偏小,定亲却最早,甚至比二姐姐赢春还要早得多,实在有些匪夷所思。
其次,习仁回忆当年是自尘十年前曾服侍乡云,两人在西边暖哥住着,夜里说悄悄话。
虽然草血秦没有明确点破,习仁和乡云聊的是什么内容,但从习仁内句,那回子不害骚,这回子怎么又害骚了可知。
两人说的应该是婚姻相关的事,跟上述大喜的话题是相关的。
逐渐当时乡云已经初步具备了男女性别意识。
根本红罗孟的年龄设置,史乡云的年龄比待遇小,待遇此时最多十四五岁。
具体可参考第四十五回,金兰气互抛金兰雨,待遇向保柴四十五今年十五岁。
那么第三十二回的乡云最多也就十三四岁,也就是说,十年前的乡云最多只有三四岁。
一个三四岁的右头,刚刚具备短期记忆的能力,连基本的性别意识都还没有完善。
这种情况下,乡云和习仁是不可能聊婚姻大事的。
若要具备这种能力和意识,至少也得是六七岁的少女。
另外,乡云如果仅仅三四岁,随身伺候的普人也会身哪娘一类,而不会是习仁这样的压缓。
而且退一万不说,实家也不会把一个三四岁的阴孩丢到假假作课,这是不符合现实的。
真正合理的解释是,使乡云进家府时一定不是的阴孩,而是个少女,所以出小人士的他会和习仁一起聊天,谈论未来婚姻的话题。
所以乡云当年进家府居住至少六岁网上,而且只会比这大,不会比这小。
如此一来,糟闻中使乡云的年龄在姐妹中属于偏大的,而且一定比临带预大,所以他定婚很早,甚至比二姐姐赢春还要早得多。
这个观点,红楼梦里有两处细节似乎可以证明,其一。
第二是二回,听取文,保育物残击,虚保拆将机之年生日,家母亲自为她过生日。
习间有个戏子长得像临带预,王夕奉出言调砍,史乡云直言点破。
书中是这么写的,奉解笑道,这个孩子半上活向一个人,你们再看不出来。
保拆心里也知道,便只一笑不肯说,保育也猜着了,一不敢说,史乡云接着笑道,道向临妹妹的母样。
此处,史乡云对临带预的称呼是临妹妹,而不是临姐姐。
有许多独者认为此处写错了。
但布红军分别翻月了红楼梦,手抄更成本,细续本,书中写的军事临妹妹。
误下其他版本都以误超为由,将临妹妹三字改成了临姐姐。
布红军思认为,此处妹妹二字并非抄错,而是早本横记时然。
第22回是典型的红楼走狗,操血秦甚至没有写完这一张。
登臣首抄本只写到西春灯迷,就夹然而止。
夹保育,临带预,削保拆的灯迷也吸书缺失。
史乡云称呼临带预为临妹妹,实属早本称呼中的漏网之云。
其二,第三是一回因其临服白手伤心。
史乡云再次作课假家,并带来了四个建文戒指,分别要送给习人金串冤养平二。
史乡云给这四人送礼,显然是因为和他们关系亲密。
其中,习人冤养是夹母身边的压缓。
史乡云是藉由夹母进入荣府,和他们关系亲密当属正常。
金串平二也出现在这个名单中则显的铺术迷里。
史乡云为什么跟金串关系亲密,操血秦没有做交代。
又或许早本中给了交代,后期又给删改了,我们不得而知。
最大的一点还是平二。
他是金临王家的人,后来随着王西奉嫁进荣国府,他才来到假家。
史乡云为什么跟他有来往,甚至专门给他准备礼物。
包括第46回,冤养女士觉冤养偶,假设强取冤养,平二在大官员里遇见冤养。
两人显化期间,冤养就说他和平二,习人,虎破,金串,玉串等人,是从小一起长大的。
再次照应了上述的疑问。
平二是经历王家的人,为什么会跟金临假家的冤养一起长大。
这个问题时难有准确答案,或许王西奉小时候曾多次带着平二来假家做课。
故而,平二得以跟假家其他压缓培养出感情来。
又或许在曹雪琴的原始设置里,平二原本就是假家的一个压缓。
后来被设置成王西奉的培防压缓,这一切都无从得知。
但有一点确是相同的,便是这四位压缓都到了婚嫁的年龄。
一一言之,平二已是假连的通缓压缓,习仁也内定给保育为准事切。
冤养显协被假设强取,金串也因为何保育言行余俱,有谋取通缓压缓的嫌疑。
以史乡云的幼小年级,为什么会和这四位压缓爱得这么近。
这只能说明,史乡云幼年级居假府时,正是这些压缓日常陪伴。
乡云和他们一起长大,有进乎同零人的嫌疑。
这些压缓都到了婚嫁年龄,史乡云便也到了定亲的时候,这也从侧面证明了史乡云的年龄问题。
故而,史乡云的纹本年龄存在相当大的问题,
造成这种情况的原因,不外忽视文稿删改后期补修,
加上草血金早早去世,不分细节并为打磨到竞山竞美的程度,
这也造就了今天红楼梦的纹本探议工作。
今天的红楼解读就到这里,我们下个视频再会。